what gives Mickey Disney Plus
subscribers awoke on New Year's Day to
find that the brand new streaming
service had removed several movies from
its library needless to say these
subscribers were less than pleased the
deletions are surprising for a couple of
reasons first everything on Disney Plus
is owned by the Walt Disney Corporation
with none of its content licensed from
other parties there doesn't appear to be
any reason for anything to ever
disappear from the streamers library in
fact many subscribers were under the
impression that the Disney Plus library
would not be rotating out titles for any
reason for another the fact that content
has begun to disappear so soon after the
streamers November 14th launch is
surprising while the list of the
vanished titles isn't very extensive the
Disney Plus library wasn't super deep to
begin with and the deletions appear to
have taken place for no good reason
perhaps the most glaring omission from
the Disney Plus library is the 1990
classic home alone which a truckload of
subscribers are likely to have watched
mere days before it vanished it is after
all a Christmas classic we suppose it
stands to reason that it may only appear
on the streamer seasonally if that's the
case however Disney should have informed
its subscribers that some titles would
only be available at certain times of
the year the flicks 1992 sequel also
disappeared although 1997 s home alone 3
which features an entirely different
cast and is nowhere near as well
regarded as the first two is still
available in addition to those films the
offerings that have mysteriously left
the service are dr. Doolittle Flicka
Pirates of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides strange magic the wonderful world
of Disney magical holiday celebration
white wilderness mickey donald goofy the
three musketeers garfield - a tale of
two kitties the 2006 remake of the
shaggy dog and the Sandlot
[Music]
to make matters worse Disney has had no
public statement to offer about the
situation as of this video the only
possible clue has come from reddit where
a single user was reportedly told by
customer service that the deletions
weren't intentional but were actually a
technical issue if it were a mere
technical problem however it seems like
Disney would have said something
publicly about it by now
in fact the mouse houses complete radio
silence isn't helping matters Disney
Plus was already looking at the loss of
a not insignificant number of
subscribers now that the first season of
its original Star Wars series the
mandalorian has concluded to follow that
up by deleting random titles from its
library doesn't seem like a great way to
reassure anyone that the service is
worth keeping
you may be wondering with all of the
titles that have suddenly departed if
Disney Plus we'll be adding anything new
to its library this month perhaps
unsurprisingly the service will be
adding plenty of new titles most
significantly last year's live-action
remakes of Aladdin and the Lion King
will be streaming on the 8th and 28
respectively already available as of
January 1st or the 2003 classic holes
the 1993 sports comedy Cool Runnings and
the fascinating 2014 documentary Marvel
75 years from pole to pop also arriving
at various points during the month will
be new episodes of Disney plus original
series sporky asks a question encore
high school musical the musical the
series Marvel's hero project Pixar in
real life Disney family Sundays and the
world according to Jeff Goldblum also
the third and final season of Marvel's
runaways will hit the platform on
January 10th and a wealth of entire
seasons of Disney Channel and Nat Geo
series such as the lodge the proud
family and dog impossible we'll also be
making their debuts it stands the reason
though that subscribers would like some
reassurance that their favorite content
isn't going to suddenly disappear from
Disney Plus at some point down the road
we'll be keeping a vigilant eye out for
any statement from the house of mouse
and we'll update you as soon as any new
information becomes available check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]